foreign
up in the 90s we saw many one-hit
wonders come and go they'd pop onto the
music scene with a piece of melodic and
lyrical Brilliance like Macarena or tub
thumping or Mambo Number Five and their
songs would be inescapable for five and
a half months piping through every
speaker ubiquitous floating on the
breeze almost uh almost becoming a part
of the atmosphere and then just as
suddenly both the song and the musical
act that produced it would disappear and
we would never hear from Lou Bega or
Chumbawamba or whoever made the Macarena
ever again maybe they turn up again
briefly years later in a VH1 where are
they now segment but usually they simply
faded from view entirely leaving us to
wonder whether they ever actually
existed
that's not how things work anymore these
days nobody ever goes away nobody ever
Fades from view we are not permitted to
forget about anyone no matter how much
we may want to because we're all
connected we're caught on the same web
and so everyone has their 15 minutes of
fame but the 15 minutes never ends
and this is true on a personal level and
it's also true in pop culture where most
pop artists are at most capable of
producing one moderately listenable song
they're one real hit but then they
Linger on indefinitely clamoring for
attention usually in ways that have
nothing to do with the music
and in recent years especially a
marginal pop star who already released
their one arguably decent or at least
maybe not completely terrible song while
cling desperately to relevance by doing
two things one becoming increasingly
vulgar and explicitly sexual and two
coming out of the closet and often
they'll come out of multiple closets
they'll come out of the closet multiple
times finding one closet after another
to emerge from we may call this the Demi
Lovato strategy though she neither
invented it nor is she the only pop star
to utilize it some came before her and
many have came after her and this is the
case certainly for uh the singer named
Sam Smith you may remember Sam Smith as
the guy who made that one song 10 years
ago stay with me is what it was called
and it enjoyed its five and a half
months of cultural ubiquity and it was
around this same time that Smith came
out of his first closet announcing to
the world that he was gay
and that Revelation didn't do much to
generate any extra interest or fame for
Sam Smith as we all kind of assume at
this point that every pop star is gay so
he said hey I'm gay and we all said uh
yeah okay
we figured
perhaps disappointed that he didn't get
more publicity mileage out of his sexual
preferences Smith began re revealing
deeper and deeper levels to his gayness
like the gay equivalent of a Russian
doll and just like an actual Russian
doll the smaller thing disguised inside
the larger thing is just a smaller
version of the larger thing so it just
kind of repeats itself in this infinite
regress a few years later Smith came out
as gender queer explaining that he quote
feels as much like a woman as a man
he was of course never asked to explain
what the hell that's supposed to mean or
how he knows what a woman feels like or
how he delineates between man feelings
and woman feelings
it's good for his sake that he wasn't
asked these questions because he
wouldn't have been able to answer them
because the term genderqueer is
completely meaningless
but genderqueer Sam Smith was about as
interesting to the public as gay Sam
Smith so he went back to the drawing
board and two years after that he came
out of his third closet he announced
that he's actually not just gay not just
genderqueer but in fact non-binary and
will now use they them pronouns
how does being non-binary differ in any
meaningful sense from being genderqueer
and what does any what do any of these
terms mean and in what way is he not
simply just a gay guy with feminine
mannerisms like a million other gay guys
well again
he was never asked those questions and
couldn't have answered them if he had
been
then another several years passed and
Sam Smith put out more music than nobody
cared about and he realized that simply
being a gay genderqueer non-binary they
them wasn't going to cut it and that's
when he decided that his only path back
to something approaching cultural
relevance was to become basically the
white male lizzo so Smith packed on 150
pounds dressed up in an outfit that
reveals far more of his body than any
human on earth ever wanted to see and he
put out a new x-rated album and music
video
and he explained this this uh this new
artistic Direction in a recent interview
that um that where he explains that that
he knows that it's it's a risky move to
do this but he's bold enough to try it
listen
the music industry is just not used to
queer artists if there was a big risk
you took with this album what would you
say it was for yourself
I'd say the biggest risk on this album
was the element of sex
wow
the music industry isn't ready for queer
artists he says
which is a bit like claiming that zumba
isn't ready for middle-aged white women
our friends at genyourself skin care
have exciting news to celebrate in 2023
they're introducing their new microbiome
moisturizer which uses the power of
probiotics to Target skin redness pesky
wrinkles Fine Lines patchy blotches and
other signs of premature aging these are
the same probiotics that are in your
yogurt as it turns out these super
ingredients can have the same nourishing
benefits on your skin as they do for
your tummy probiotic
tummy you just forced me to say the word
tummy they could help your tummy
probiotic extracts Target bad bacteria
and restore balance to your Skin's
protected barrier now every genucel most
popular package includes their new
probiotic moisturizer free with your
order my talent manager Tessa uses
genucel under eye treatment to help get
rid of the bags under her eyes it makes
her look less tired after dealing with
me every day which is uh no small feed
so right now you can get genucel's most
popular package for 70 off visit
genucel.com Walsh and get your probiotic
moisturizer today use code walls to
check out for an extra 10 off your
entire purchase at genyourself.com
Welsh he also says that the biggest risk
he's taking is being sexual
I mean that's a pretty big risk we have
to admit I mean it takes a lot of guts
to do the same thing that literally
every other person in your profession is
doing and has already done and has been
doing for decades
following the easiest and safest Trend
now there's a risk I mean that's
boldness if I ever saw it
next he's going to tell me that he that
he went out on a limb and picked the
Chiefs to go to the Super Bowl this year
I mean this guy I mean sorry this them
he knows how to take risks big risks
granted he might be the first pop star
star to go this direction while looking
like he plays right tackle on the
Detroit Lions practice squad
though on second thought I guess uh
lizzo has him beat there as well so even
on that point he's he's not the first
so Smith's latest musical effort may not
be risky may not be bold may not be
revolutionary
but it is at least we will admit
totally repulsive and grotesque
and this is normally the part where I
would Play a clip of his disgusting
music video that has gone viral entirely
for being disgusting but I'm actually
not going to do that in this case so I'm
not going to force you to start your
Monday that way
um suffice it to say that Smith's new
music video for his song which is called
I'm not here to make friends shows the
morbidly obese singer and women's
underwear dancing awkwardly with both
men and women wearing something similar
to assless chaps who then start humping
the floor with their bare butts sticking
up at which point streams of P start
spraying all over them and it gets worse
from there but I'm realizing that
describing it may even be more
objectionable than just watching it so
you get the gist anyway
now
pointing out how morally debased all of
this is
just as it's no use observing how our
society day by day comes to not only
resemble but in every sense rival Sodom
and Gomorrah and that call that all goes
without saying at this point and it's
also exactly what these
attention-starved ugly degenerate morons
want us to say
it is true that Sam Smith is a filthy
hideous pervert it's also true that he
wants us to say that about him after all
as we've learned from all of these Sam
Smith that came before this Sam Smith
part of being a pervert is getting off
on other people noticing that you're a
pervert like the thrill he gets from
hearing people describing that way is
part of
why he's a pervert and what makes him a
pervert to begin with
which isn't to say that we shouldn't
point it out but rather that after we've
delivered the moral condemnation this
kind of garbage calls for and deserves
we should also say the thing that is
just as true and also the one thing that
Sam Smith does not want us to say
the thing that those of his ilk fear the
most because they know it is true
is that this routine along with being
debased and disgusting and morally
prayed is also boring it is dirty and
stupid and gross and Evil and totally
utterly tiresome boring played out
we've seen it a million times already
they cannot shock us anymore as a
culture we are sadly far too jaded to be
scandalized by anything you cannot
scandalize us you can't do it
our eyes and Minds have have grown
essentially calloused
we've been swimming in this muck and
filth for so long that another bucket
may be demoralizing and sad but it can
never shock us it can never surprise us
to be intentionally ugly in a world of
ugliness only means that you blend in
you become part of the background
now you may be noticed for a brief
moment but then you Fade Into the
surroundings and you become merely part
of the fecal flecked landscape
a decadent Society is very generous to
perverts in many ways but the one thing
that the perverts are forced to give up
the one price that they must pay is the
element of surprise
you can't surprise us anymore
and most of all they lose their status
as revolutionaries
they're not challenging the system but
rather acting as Guardians and
reinforcers of it
now if Sam Smith really wanted to shock
us
therefore he would have created
something good
something meaningful
something beautiful and and true
now that would be something we're not
used to okay you want to give the music
industry something it's not used to
how about beauty and Truth
but that requires Talent
and moral Clarity and an IQ somewhere
above the freezing point
which puts it out of Sam Smith's reach
and that is why Sam Smith is today
canceled
and I'll do it for this portion so let's
move over to the members block if you're
not a member yet you can become a member
and use code wall to check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]